[Musique]
mais c'est le premier ministre depuis le
22 février dernier une grande partie du
peuple algérien est descendue dans la
rue pour s'opposer à la 5e' un mandat du
président bouteflika dans un esprit
pacifique il faut le souligner cette
mobilisation inédite dans cette forme
depuis très longtemps a évidemment
contribué à faire évoluer les positions
du pouvoir d'abord lorsque le podium
bouteflika a annoncé s'il ne terminerait
pas son second mandat s'ils venaient à
être réélu puis hier soir lorsqu'il a
annoncé qu'ils renonçaient à une
nouvelle candidature
invoquant cette fois sonnac et sa santé
le président emmanuel macron accueilli
avec satisfaction ces annonces appelant
au passage à la transition d'une durée
raisonnable
on le sait nos deux pays entretiennent
depuis longtemps des relations complexes
passionnel d'étroites pourriez où
monsieur le ministre nous préciser la
position de votre gouvernement
ces dernières évolutions qui doit
maintenant s'engager c'est une dynamique
à même de répondre aux aspirations
profondes du peuple algérien et surtout
la mise en place d'un calendrier
politique de transition raisonnable
puisque l'affichage et le respect de ce
calendrier est une condition de
crédibilité est essentielle à l'ensemble
du processus
c'est le voeu que nous formons nous qui
souhaitons une algérie stable prospère
et unie
c'est d'abord la responsabilité des
algériens eux-mêmes
nous le disons en toute amitié et avec
toute l'attention qui est la nôtre sur
la situation actuelle
monsieur le premier ministre nous avons
bien vu que l'éducation nationale
organisera des débats dans les lycées
pour faire remonter les idées des
lycéens sur ce sujet alors je le précise
au passage qu'en même temps vous
repoussez le projet de loi sur l'énergie
c'est un véritable paradoxe alors voilà
mes questions quelles sont vos idées
quelles sont vos propositions pour
inverser ou du moins pour contenir le
réchauffement climatique qui n'est pas
un fantasme de professeurs caussinus
mais bien une réalité
quelles mesures allez vous prendre pour
que la france respecte ses engagements
de 2015 et enfin quelles actions en
europe pour qu'enfin notre société
avance et ne reste pas silencieuse
en attendant que survienne la
catastrophe beaucoup a été fait depuis
une quinzaine d'années pour que dans les
programmes de l'école le développement
durable soit centrale nous devons
maintenant mettre en action l'ensemble
des citoyens et la jeunesse nous avons
aujourd'hui un label dans nos
établissements que nous appelons le 3d
qui permet aux élèves de se mobiliser
eux mêmes pour trouver des solutions
récemment j'étais à conflans sainte
honorine où les élèves ont fait baisser
au monde divisé de moitié la baisse la
part dont la facture énergétique de leur
établissement leur vision sur la lumière
le chauffage les enjeux quotidiens de
l'environnement est en train
d'influencer leur commune leur famille
leur environnement ils peuvent donc être
les vecteurs de ce changement concret au
quotidien ils ont dû aussi des idées à
l'échelle nationale et à l'échelle
internationale l'échelle européenne est
aussi très important que nous rappelions
ce matin que trois directives ont été
adoptées à la fin de l'année 2018 pour
mettre fin à trois pesticides qui était
tueur d'abeilles
il ya donc des progrès qu'ils ont
accomplis ils se font grâce à la
mobilisation de des citoyens du
gouvernement mais croyez le ce qui va se
passer vendredi aura beaucoup
d'importance puisque le 5 avril prochain
nous réunirons l'ensemble des des
représentants lycéens de france pour
précisément structurer ses propositions
de la jeunesse
[Musique]